اذن بعضنا فشلنا باول توقعين مش راح نرحل
راح نرجع ونتوقع كمان مباراتين فرنسا
وانجلترا والمغرب والبرتغال طبعا امبارح
كرواتيا عملت مفاجاه على البرازيل ما حدا
فيلومني على هذا التوقع لانكم متوقع
البرازيل ولكن ااا ال- ال- النتيجه الاخرى
طبعا كانت عكس الاحصائيات وعكس الارقام
وهي فوز الارجنتين على هولندا وكانت طبعا
تستحق الارجنتين الفوز بكل همم تاكيد وبكل
الامان بصراحه يستحق المنتخب الارجنتيني
انه يعدي الى نصف النهائي ولكن اليوم
تعالوا هيك ندردش يعني ونتوقعات خفيفه
ونظيفه بلكي يضبط التوقع منها التوقعات
وهمم ونكون عن جد استحق لقب ملك التوقعات
خلينا نبدا بالمباراه الثانيه
مباراه متوازن جدا توقع فيها يعني قريب
جدا بالمنتخبين همم منتخبات من اكثر
المنتخبات تسجيلات الاهداف بالبطوله
المنتخب ب 12 هدف تقريبا في هذه البطوله
وهو اقوى خط هجوم مع المنتخب البرتغالي ان
المنتخب الفرنسي هو ثاني اقوى هجوم ايضا
في البطوله ااه من ناحيه عدد الاهداف
المنتخبين لديهم عندهم فاعليه كبيره عندهم
همم خطوره على المرمى دائما عنده الحلول
هجوميه كثيره عندهم خط وسط مميز جدا صحيح
البعض يعتبر انه خط وسط منتخب فرنسا يمكن
نقصته شويه خبره ولكن بكل صدقني في هذه
البطوله قدم بطوله كبيره حتى الان همم
بعمليه بدء الهجمه وبناء اللاعب رابيو
صاحب الانطلاقات الرائعه من الثلث الثاني
لثلث الامامي كمان قدم بطوله كبيره جدا
وقدم اداء كبير جدا في منتصف الملعب وربيع
طبعا لاعب خبره بالتاكيد
وبالاضافه الى جريزمان مفاجاه في هذه
البطوله جريزمان اللاعب يلعب كاساره العاب
واللي هو اللاعب اللي بيصنع الاهداف
بالثلث الامامي وبالتالي وسط منتخب فرنسا
وسط ممتاز كان وسط متماسك وسط قوي جدا
بالمقابل وسط انجلترا ايضا كان وسط جيد
جدا في دك للرايس عم يبدا الهجمه مع جون
ستونز اللي هو جون سونس بالمناسبه هو اكثر
اللاعبيه المنتخب الانجليزي تمريرا للكرات
همم جود برينجام هو اللاعب البينقل الكره
للثلث الامامي وشفنا انه هاري كين اللي هو
اكثر لاعب في منتخب انجلترا عام الاساسي
في هذه البطوله هو عم بيلعب دور تقريبا
صانع الالعاب بالنسبه للمنتخب الانجليزي
لحتى يصنع الاسلاكه ويصنع
للجناح الاخر اللي بيكون موجود ان كان في
الفوضن او كان راشفورد راشفورد مناسب هو
الذهب المنتخب الانجليزي حتى الان طبعا
بمركز حراسه المرمى بالتاكيد بيكفورد عامل
بطوله افضل الى حد
من اكثر الحراس ايضا بتصديات بتصدي تقريبا
41 كره على المرمى الانجليزي حتى الان
وهذا رقم جيد جدا بالنسبه
ولكن مستواها مش ثابت متذبذب وهذا الخوف
دائما على المنتخب
نسيب رايي الشخصي كيليان مبابي هو نقطه
الخطر الاساسيه على منتخب انجلترا وسال
عنها المنتخب الانجليزي كثيرا بس كان
الجواب دائما ان احنا مش عم نلعب ضد
امبابه عم نلعب ضد المنتخب الفرنسي عامه
توقع الشخصي بكل صراحه نسبه للارقام هذا
مش توقع مبني على ولا شيء هذا توقع مبني
على الارقام انجلترا الاقرب للوصول الى
الدور المقبل وانا ما دخلني اذا فازت
فرنسا فانا ما دخلني عشاق المنتخب
الانجليزي على كل حال ننتقل الى مباراه
المغرب
والبرتغال طبعا مباراه صعب جدا عن المنتخب
المغربي برايي الشخصي لن تكون اصعب من
مباراه المنتخب الاسباني لانه الاستحواذ
او التكاته او سميها ماشي هاي من اصعب
الطرق اللي ممكن يواجهها اي دفاع لانه
بيحرمك من الكره وبتصير مضطر انك تعتمد
على قوتك البدنيه ونفسيا صعب على اللاعبين
النظام الفتره طويله بالملعب بدون كره
وبالتالي الامر صعب راح يكون كان على
المنتخب المغربي المنتخب البرت مش من
نوعيه الفرق اللي بتستحوذ على الكره نعم
كعدد تمريرات كنسبه تمريرات دقيقه المغرب
هي او هو الاقل بين الفرق الثمانيه التي
تاهلت الى الدور بانهائي بدقه تمرير تصل
79% ومعدل تمريرات تقريبا بين 325 الى 350
تمريره وهو اقل رقم تمريرات موجود
بالبطوله لحد الان وهذا يفسر ان المغرب
يعتمد على اللاعب المباشر على الدفاع على
الكرات الطوليه نحو المهاجمين وعلى مباراه
الخصم بالهجمات المرتده لا اعتقد ان وليد
الركراك اليوم راح يفتح مصحات اعتقد انه
راح يلعب بطريقه هجومي راح يلتزم بطريقته
بنفس الاسلوب بنفس اللاعبين اذا كان نايف
اكره جاهز راح يلعب اساسي اذا ما كان جاهز
اتمنى انه يلعب بامير همم اساسي او همم
اكيد طبعا راح يلعب بدر بنون او يميك واحد
منهم ولكن اتمنى امير لانه اخذ شويه همم
سايس في المباراه الماضيه البرتغال
مشكلتها والفرق بينها وبين اسبانيا انه
متعدده الحلول همم تخترق من ثلاث جهات
تقريبا بنسب متشابه او متقارب جدا من
العمق من اليمين من اليسار عند حلول بنص
الملعب بوجود برونو فرنانديز اللي هو احد
افضل صانع اي لاعب في هذه البطوله حتى
الان برناردو سيلفا صاحب عنصر مفاجاه اللي
بيعمل لك همم حاله من من المفاجاه بثلث
الامامي وطبعا عندهم جونزالو راموس اللي
فاجئ الكل في المباراه الماضيه وسجل
هاتريك هل سيلعب اساسي ولا رونالدو سيلعب
اساسي هذا امر اخر برتغال عند حارس مميز
جدا تصدى له 46 كره تقريبا وبالتالي همم
حارس ممتاز وقرنت بيبونه 26 مع انه لاعب
مباراه اقل ولكن هذا امر لا ينقص من قيمه
ولكن يعلي من قيمه حارس البرتغال طبعا
الدفاع المغرب هو اقوى دفاع بالبطوله وهو
هجوميا هو اضعف هجوم بالبطوله الدفاع
البرتغال هو اضعف دفاع بين الفريق
الاسباني المتاهله وهجوميا هو اقوى هجوم
في البطوله الى جانب المنتخب الانجليزي ب
12 هدف يعني عم نحكي عن اقوى دفاع مع اضعف
دفاعه واقوى هجوم مع هجوم بالطرق الثمانيه
المتاهله شخصيا عندي احساس المغرب راح
تعمل المفاجاه ولكن منطقيا البرتغال هي
المرشحه للتاهل الى الدور المقبل
[موسيقى]